لمدة أسبوعين من كل عام ،
تطفو هذه الفوانيس الملونة العملاقة على طول
نهر نام جونج الكوري وتحولها إلى
مشهد من الضوء واللون
يقام مهرجان جين-جو نام جونج
للفوانيس في جيندو بكوريا الجنوبية سنويًا في كل
موسم خريف مجموعة متنوعة من
الفوانيس الملونة التي تصور الكنوز الوطنية
يطفو التراث الثقافي الكوري
على طول نهر num gum ويمكن
للزوار ركوب القوارب لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة
بالإضافة إلى الفوانيس النابضة بالحياة
هناك عروض حية
لعروض نافورة الموسيقى وبالطبع
لا يكتمل أي مهرجان بدون الألعاب النارية.
أصل هذا الفانوس
يعود تاريخ المهرجان إلى القرن الخامس عشر الميلادي عندما كان
سكان جينجو يضيئون الفوانيس الراغبين
في العودة الآمنة
لأفراد عائلاتهم خلال الغزو الياباني
، ويستمر المهرجان اليوم تخليداً
لذكرى هؤلاء الجنود الذين لقوا حتفهم وهم يخدمون
زوار بلادهم في المهرجان.
رغباتك الخاصة على
الفوانيس وإما أن تعلقها في
نفق المعرض أو تطفو عليها  ه
النهر